how long did you know him before you got
married to him um a little over a year I
guess that's it yeah not maybe a year
and a half why you were really smitten
with this guy we we met in October and
then we talked on the phone for a few
months before we went on on our first
date but it it was good it kind of laid
some um foundation and if you're just
talking on the phone you got to which
neither one of us are talkers like it's
it's we are very comfortable with
silence and I'm comfortable in life with
silence where didd you go on your first
date with this guy I need to know stuff
um it was New Year's Eve and uh there
was a team party and I actually invited
myself to the team party he moved slow
are these guys very slow and I was like
you know New Year's Eve's coming up are
you doing anything he's like there's a
team party and I said do you need a date
and that was the first kiss on midnight
at New Year Eve wow it was look at this
that's romantic that is romantic